cows fo get calm that sounds like he
made that up in college I did I made it
up in five minutes okay I never looked
back
[Music]
alright guys we are here with Thomas
Frank from college info geek comm and
your personal astrophysicist dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson and geek sympathizer a
geek sympathizer and me just a geek
what's the number one thing that people
want to know seriously like what cuz I
know your thing is about knowing like if
I don't if I want to do better or know
something more you guys are kind of in
the same space you know then it's like
you know we are into knowing into
knowing what's like the number one thing
what do they ask and it is it is Bar
None how do I focus how do I stop
getting distracted and how do I motivate
myself to actually hang on this is your
answer put this down I think if you
google how to stop wasting time like my
so I could you know I have a program on
my phone that literally blocks all the
websites that I tend to go to when I'm
distracted
I can't go to Reddit anymore you got to
wrap your own wrist yeah well I I think
that like training wheels or like
limitations actually do help us and we
don't have them then we tend to just I
don't know go to our base instincts do
you think you're more productive when
you're multitasking
no okay but do a lot of people who
believe they are multitasking versus
multi focus right because multitasking
like you can ride a bike and talk on the
phone at the same time because your
brain has sort of gotten bike riding to
a second nature thing right but if
you're trying to multi focus you're
trying to do some astrophysics and also
so you can have two Joann anomic tasks
yeah yeah if you've big city stressful
memory then multitasking is you know
playing and singing at the same time
right if you practice both you can do it
so I could do astrophysics and chew gum
at the same time yes well how good a
two-income are you pretty good I haven't
asked yeah I go wake me gum the way back
when I think about learning how to learn
and learning effectively and you know
all these tools I have on my phone to
kill distractions for me it's just like
am i interested in the thing I'm
learning about and because I have the
opportunity to talk with you I want to
ask you like how do we get people
interested in science and stem and
things like that and stay interested as
it gets difficult
mm-hmm so I have a Orthodox an
unorthodox view on that okay I don't
think the challenge is to get people
interested because as children we are
all curious about the natural world to
the point where we put our lives at risk
in the expression of that curiosity well
what is the the cliff ledge let me crawl
over to it what is this knife
what is this fire dial it back one notch
and the curiosity may just result in a
completely messy home but you don't have
kids so that you maintain them neat home
that's not the goal yes the goal is you
want to raise kids so it's gonna raise
kids let him explore you want to raise
free-range children I hear they're
delicious we're gonna try not to make
that that's why I might have charts this
is boho now you understand why we have
Chuck I have no filter so so what you do
is you don't get in their way and you
nurture the curiosity they already have
then they become curious adults okay and
if they become a curious an adult as
adults
that's a scientist yes autistic it'd who
never grew up
well they grew up but they're still as
curious as they were as kids if there's
something weird happening over there and
you have kids and you have scientists
you have everybody else the kids and the
scientist will run to guess that let's
figure it out
oh my gosh let's test it and everybody
else why they always die first in a
horror film
what is that and plus I feel strongly
that the challenges of the world do not
pivot on whether we have scientifically
literate children they pivot on the
weather we have scientifically literate
adults mmm
adults outnumber kids 5 to 1 adults vote
wheel resources money power the heads of
agency heads of state heads of
organizations yeah and if you have such
a community of people who are not
scientifically literate if they have
power of decision over others that's a
recipe for a disaster it's the
unraveling of an informed democracy and
so for me if you fix that problem the
kid problem is solved overnight
you don't have debates about whether
science should be in a curriculum
because all the adults know that it
should be so your hope is moving us
toward a society where people who are
scientifically literate are in positions
of power in position of power and I
think that's a faster solution than
training the 8th grader to be
scientifically literate than waiting
around thirty years and so they become a
head of agency so that the world can
become scientifically literate I'm not
that patient yeah I don't know how to
get people like that into positions of
power I suppose my my wheelhouse is
hopefully being a little more patient
let me be more softer and say they don't
have to be in power but who's in power
needs to know that they need to be
listened to yes because they have access
to the operations of nature and
legislation that depends on an accurate
understanding of the operations of
nature requires enlightened leaders who
if not themselves are scientifically
literate they have advisors who are yeah
and know how to heed such advice so what
we need I think transitioning through
middle school is a culture which I think
is a little bit there where curiosity
and learning and the embracing of
education become value commodities in
the dating circles now I don't need
everybody to be a scientist but just
understand what science is how and why
it works and when ninety seven percent
of scientists achieve an observation
will hit experimental consensus that
something is true you don't turn around
say well I choose to believe the two
percent because I prefer that yeah that
it's not this is not a healthy world to
be in that's how people are carrying on
anyway if you guys are interested in
learning how to learn becoming better
learners I think one of the best ways to
do it is to get actively involved in
what you're learning whether it's
calculus or astronomy or machine
learning and if you're interested in any
of those topics or anything else in the
realms of math and science and computer
science brilliant org is an amazing
resource that is built around the
concept of active learning so instead of
sitting in the classroom passively
listening to a lecture talking about
your dog's name on day one you're thrown
into a problem and then you have to
solve it and I think we were talking
about interest earlier this is why I
like brilliant because the the active
challenges build that interest and they
get you really you know just really want
to solve that problem and that
effectively helps you learn a lot better
than that passive learning so if you
want to start learning for free today
you can go over to brilliant org slash
start talk right that's right and the
first seventy-nine people who sign up
we're also gonna get 20% off of their
first annual premium subscription so
definitely head over there and sign up
today if you want to see more videos
from star tall hit the subscribe par and
click the little Bell button to get
notifications every single time that we
upload a video and give us a like or a
comment to express your passion as
always I bid you to keep looking up
[Music]